dans les kiosques que tout est résumé
les journaux d'opposition relate l'appel
à la transition civile lancé par pascal
affi n'guessan et l'ancien président
henri konan-bédié les deux candidats en
lice sur les quatre au total dans cette
élection présidentielle il demande aussi
la fin du mandat d'alassane ouattara qui
s'est achevée officiellement
techniquement en tout cas samedi à
minuit et puis les journaux du pouvoir
eux ils crient déjà à la victoire du
président sortant
il salue aussi un vote massif
ici à yopougon dans un quartier calme de
la commune d'abidjan les ivoiriens ils
veulent tant finir avec les cycles de
violence entre peur et dénis est leur
intérêt qu'on appelle de tout ce qui va
nous arriver parce qu'actuellement le
vih est un qui non c'est pas ça tourne à
quoi ya pas d autre à blaye ya rien qui
va arriver et la chance finit tout est
flou nous siphonner les gens fuient par
le vénézuélien a pour part face moral au
travail mais à cause des sages pourquoi
l'otan avait passé j'ai peur nous sommes
ici à yopougon kouté c'est une commune
populaire et défavorisés d'abidjan un
quartier bouclé par les services de
sécurité vous allez voir ce pick up qui
est installé sur ce rond point avant
l'annoncé des résultats officiels du
premier tour de scrutin présidentiel
regarder encore sur ces images de claire
nico et bien cette barricade de fortune
érigé par les populations pour se
protéger c'est vrai que le 31 octobre
durant la journée de scrutin est bien là
yopougon kouté a été le théâtre de
heurts
on y déplore un mort c'est un jeune
faisant partie de ce que l'on appelle
les microbes ces jeunes qui seraient
instrumentalisée pour semer le trouble
de plus même le samedi à partir de 14 à
côté ont été victimes ce que vous voyez
des barrages pour autoriser là on a été
victimes des attaques
ici un jeune qui détenait des armes
blanches de nomades des couteaux des
boutons d'autres même des kalachnikovs
pour la vue mais qui aurait été victime
le moment on était venu d attaque ici
et aux données qui sont aussi des mondes
évidemment on a peur on a tellement peur
à son sympa on s'attend on en sait pas
quand ça tangue parce que nous savons et
nous disons toujours que nous voulons
des élections et fait du monde
transparent et inclusif
pas de violence mais nous n'avons pas
parce que il y aura des relations
devenues des démons définitive l'on
sépare constatant samedi et dimanche la
population à est restée terrée chez elle
les ivoiriens ici refusent très souvent
de parler de se livrer devant les
caméras et cela par peur ils ont repris
c'est vrai le travail ici mais il n'y a
pas foule